[Music]
on this Friday night will temperatures
rise Canada's economy is cooling this is
an economy that's just been allowed to
run too hot for too long why
unemployment is up even though new jobs
are being added and what it could mean
for interest rates Ukraine receives a
controversial weapon it's a difficult
decision what Washington is donating
that other countries including Canada
have banned plus Space Cowboy I was
definitely a little bit nervous we speak
with Canadian astronaut Jeremy Hansen
who's leading the charge at the Calgary
Stampede
global national with Farah NASA
reporting tonight Jeff simple good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin with good news and bad news on the
Canadian economy the labor market is
showing signs of softening but likely
not enough to prevent another interest
rate hike Canada added 60 000 jobs last
month driven by big gains in full-time
positions but despite those new jobs the
unemployment rate actually Rose to 5.4
percent that's the highest level in over
a year analysts say that apparent
contradiction is a result of our
fast-growing population Canada surpassed
40 million people last month
Canada's June job growth was greater
than many economists had expected and as
a result many now believe the Bank of
Canada will raise its key interest rate
again next week Mackenzie gray has our
top story tonight
here's an example here's a 1972 Gretch
after 37 years Spaceman music continues
to be an audible institution we have a
really long loyal clientele that have
you know
bought a first guitar with us and now
they're retiring kind of thing with the
best vintage music gear in the capital
business has been brisk that's LED slow
Tom Stewart to bring on two new
employees adding to his team of 12. you
know we always try to run on on sort of
Escalade and staff because that's that's
the biggest you know payroll is the
biggest expense of any business
Spaceman just one of thousands of
businesses across the country to boost
their staff in June 60 000 new jobs in
Canada is it's a very big number that's
always going to be representative of a
strong labor market in Canada those
numbers bolstered by the highest
immigration level since 1913 and while
those new Canadians have been eager to
find work the big increase to the labor
pool drove up the unemployment level to
5.4 percent the highest in a year strong
dog gains just not enough to absorb all
of the new entrants into the labor
market the hot jobs market and inflation
well above two percent has led money
markets to predict the Bank of Canada
will increase interest rates again next
week pushing them to the highest level
in a generation this is an economy
that's just been allowed to run too hot
for too long and the Bank of Canada is
on the scene they've put a fire hose on
the economy it's just taking a little
while a little while to to get all the
Flames out the housing market also
running red hot a potential 25 basis
point hike will bring more into mortgage
holders but also bring hope for some
prospective home buyers house prices
could soon decline I enjoy the summer uh
get out to the lake if you can have a
beer on the Terrace and forget about
real estate until the fall if you follow
that advice and have a beer by the lake
expect that housing inventory will
increase by the time the leaves change
colors and some homeowners could be
forced to sell Jeff with mortgage rates
above six percent
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks Mac
and there's more economic turmoil coming
from the ongoing Port strike in BC it is
now day seven of that job action and
every hour millions of dollars of cargo
is being disrupted negotiations have
stalled and the two sides are trading
barbs as neither garcha reports there
are growing calls for the government to
intervene
as cargo piles up there is no end in
sight to the week-long BC Port strike
[Applause]
for concerns about wages Contracting and
automation hundreds of workers rallied
on Thursday three times the employer
walked away from the table
three times
the employer has asked for binding
arbitration as an estimated 3.5 billion
dollars worth of goods remains stuck due
to the port shutdown that's also a
Transit point for the U.S market
um something like 10 of our fashion that
comes into the United States comes in
through those ports the American Apparel
and Footwear Association says members
are diverting cargo to other ports on
the west coast that's going to create
sort of reputational uncertainty which
may make companies rethink whether they
should be building up that business in
Vancouver or whether they should be
looking at other ports business groups
are urging the federal government to
step in there's a precedent for the
federal government to do this they
intervened in 2021 in the Montreal Port
dispute and so it's time for them to
intervene in this dispute
in 2021 Ottawa forced an end to the
strike by Montreal longshoremen with
Automation and AI becoming a new part of
our Workforce and their concerns about
their jobs being ultimately pushed out
are legitimate ones this Toronto lawyer
says enacting Back To Work legislation
in this case could disrupt years of
Labor peace in the industry taking the
auction of forcing the employees to go
back to work would be agreeing with the
employer essentially and potentially
mowing over all of the concerns that the
union has brought forth the federal
labor Minister's office says he met with
his U.S counterpart and has spoken with
opposition members and labor leaders to
build a coalition of pressure to get a
deal at the table
Global News Vancouver
Ukraine's military claims to be gaining
ground today clawing back one kilometer
of land near the eastern city of bakmut
new video just released by Ukraine's
Armed Forces claims to show an air raid
on Russian troops near the city it comes
as Ukraine's president aims to make
diplomatic gains Vladimir zielinski is
touring NATO member countries ahead of
next week's NATO Summit asking for more
military aid and today one major arms
announcement came from Washington but as
Redmond Shannon reports that U.S
donation includes a highly controversial
weapon
Vladimir zielenski visited three NATO
countries Friday the Czech Republic
Slovakia and turkey a quick diplomatic
tour ahead of next week's NATO Summit to
push for Sweden's accession and
eventually the same for Ukraine
zielinski made further calls for more
long-range missiles on a day when NATO's
most powerful member announced a new
donation of arms to Ukraine including
controversial cluster Munitions we
recognize that cluster Munitions create
a risk of Civilian harm from unexploded
ordinance this is why we've the defer
deferred the decision for as long as we
could cluster Munitions are bombs that
scatter smaller explosives across a
large area like landmines some can
remain unexploded later injuring
civilians the White House says the
unexploded ordinance figure could be as
high as 2.5 percent and suggested that
these are not its first choice of
artillery shipments we need to build a
bridge from where we are today to when
we have enough monthly production of
unitary rounds 111 countries including
Canada and most NATO members prohibit
the use production and export of cluster
Munitions those Nations do not include
the U.S Russia or Ukraine Human Rights
Watch says its investigations show both
Russia and Ukraine have used cluster
Munitions in the war causing civilian
injuries and deaths we're not commenting
on any of the other weapons except for
plastic Munitions because they have
that is under international law NATO
Chief yens stoltenberg was Norwegian
prime minister in 2008 when his country
hosted the signing of the convention on
cluster Munitions the difference is that
Russia is used in customization to
attack to invade Ukraine
a Ukraine is using close diminution to
protect itself critics of cluster bombs
say it matters little who fires them if
they later injure or kill a civilian
Redmond Shannon Global News London
as Redmond mentioned cluster Munitions
release thousands of tiny Bombs over a
large area up to the size of a football
field making them as deadly as they are
indiscriminate
the Kremlin denies using cluster bombs
but on our visit to Ukraine last year we
saw evidence to the contrary we found
residential neighborhoods like this one
near harkive riddled with remnants of
Russian cluster Munitions and we also
saw examples of rounds that had landed
but failed to explode the result is that
they essentially become like booby traps
hidden in the grass ready to explode on
contact we saw some so sensitive even a
change in temperature can set them off
While others can lay dormant and hidden
for years before exploding many
Ukrainian Farmers have been killed
plowing their fields cluster Munitions
have also been recovered from children's
playgrounds experts estimate it will
take decades to clear Ukraine of
landmines and unexploded Ordnance
well this summer is barely underway but
already it's on track to be one of the
hottest on record temperatures are
soaring here in Canada and around the
world on Thursday this planet recorded
its hottest day ever for the fourth day
in a row with the average global
temperature climbing above 17 degrees
Celsius
large swaths of Canada from coast to
coast to coast are under heat warnings
tonight temperatures are forecast to
climb above 30 in parts of BC while in
Quebec and The Maritime Provinces the
humidex is making it feel close to 40
degrees
and that sweltering heat will likely
stick around for the weekend Global News
meteorologist Ross Hall joins me now so
Ross when can people expect some relief
hi Jeff well already some relief for
residents of Southern Ontario after the
passage of a cold front on Friday so
less humid that humidex how the body
feels in a particular air mass has been
in that uncomfortable range of between
35 and 40. that range of humidex will
continue for portions of Southwestern
Quebec The Maritime Provinces due to
this Ridge of high pressure that is
circulating in that warmth and
especially that humidity so you can see
the heat warnings continue across Quebec
in towards the maritimes and that will
be the situation heading into the
weekend some cooler conditions expected
by early next week a different type of
heat a drier heat but hot nonetheless
across portions of the BC Coast the
North Coast Inland sections the Central
Coast the Fraser Canyon up towards
Northwest Territories in Yukon where
temperatures are 5 to 10 degrees above
above average that will continue to the
weekend we've got a rising in the jet
stream a heat Ridge basically building
and that's going to stick around which
is not a good thing for the Wildfire
situation that fire risk will be at
extreme heading into the weekend for
some areas Jeff all right meteorologist
Ross Hall thanks Ross
hurricanes on the horizon coming up like
forecasters are upgrading their
predictions for this year's hurricane
season
this Atlantic hurricane season is
proving difficult to predict
unprecedented ocean temperatures have
experts revising their forecast for the
third time this year researchers are now
describing the hurricane season as
borderline hyperactive with violent
storms fueled by unusually warm seawater
Jackson prosco has the details when
hurricane Ian slammed into Florida last
September as a powerful category 4 storm
it killed more than 160 people caused
tens of billions of dollars in damage
and wiped out entire communities this
year there are above average odds of a
similar storm striking again due to
climate change we're seeing like right
now in the Atlantic animals temperatures
so this will
um enhance the hurricane formation and
make them stronger
researchers at Colorado State University
are now predicting an overactive
hurricane season with 18 named storms
nine hurricanes and three to five major
hurricanes of Category 3 or higher the
odds of a major hurricane making
landfall in the U.S are 50 percent
what's so unusual is that this is an El
Nino year when weather patterns should
make it harder for hurricanes to form
they think that the Sea Service
temperature thing May kind of overwhelm
it because it's because we're at record
levels the highest ocean temperatures
ever recorded have created plenty of
fuel for hurricanes and just like when
Fiona slammed into Atlantic Canada last
year as the most destructive
post-tropical system on record
conditions are ripe for storms to stay
stronger farther north which makes
places you know like like the
Mid-Atlantic and New England and even
the maritimes of Canada uh more
vulnerable with three named storms
already on the books and hurricane
season just beginning
yeah people up and down the vulnerable
coasts are being told to prepare for
what our warming Planet May deliver in
the coming months Jackson prosco Global
News Washington
I believe it's only a matter of time
before we see thousands of robots just
like me out there making a difference
will robots steal our jobs we'll ask
them next
[Music]
in Ecuador Rescuers worked through the
night to free dozens of people trapped
on one of the world's highest Cable Car
systems
[Music]
some have to get down the hard way with
Crews helping them slide down ropes from
the suspended gondolas While others were
eventually able to walk off after being
trapped for nearly 10 hours in the end
everyone got out safely the keto Cable
Car Rises nearly 4 000 meters above sea
level
well there's a fear among some that one
day we may need to be rescued from
robots trying to take over but today at
the world's first Press Conference held
by robots they offered an assurance
that's not the case
do you believe that uh
Your Existence will destroy a human
being I will be working alongside humans
to provide assistance and support and
will not be replacing any existing jobs
all right if you say so the nine
human-like robots gathered at the AI for
good conference in Geneva where
organizers are making the case for the
use of artificial intelligence and
robots to help resolve some of the
world's biggest challenges
[Music]
Space Cowboy Up Next we hear from the
Canadian astronaut taking the Reign said
this year's Calgary Stampede
[Music]
welcome back the cowboy boots and 10
gallon hats were out in full force for
the Calgary Stampede
[Applause]
astronaut Jeremy Hanson
it was all smiles for Canadian astronaut
Jeremy Hansen this Year's parade
Marshall an estimated 300 thousand
Spectators lined the streets to kick off
the annual event I spoke to Hanson
earlier today before he hopped on that
horse
and Canadian astronaut Jeremy Henson
joins us now from the Calgary Stampede
bringing new meaning to the term space
cowboy Jeremy swapping the helmet for
the hat today but you're looking good
nice to see you I want to ask you you're
a busy guy why did you want to take the
time to do this today
that's really simple for me just
connecting uh with Canadians and
visitors to the Stampede and the
Canadian space agency we're up to big
things on this Artemis 2 mission and the
reason a Canadian is going on this
mission is because of the efforts of so
many Canadians operating under a common
vision for decades now and what I want
to what I want to do here is just be a
mirror for people just reflect back to
Canadians hey Canada is on this mission
for a reason and it's you it's the all
the things that we've done to have a big
Vision we have so much to offer the
international collaboration that we're
been invited to be the second country to
go to the moon this is an incredible
compliment for the country and I just
want people to be as proud of themselves
as I am of them and I'm certainly proud
of you uh speaking of the Stampede you
grew up on a farm near London Ontario I
believe your kids were born there in
Alberta did those rural routes influence
your path to becoming an astronaut
without without doubt uh growing up on a
farm I learned a lot about community and
a lot about teamwork and it built a lot
of confidence uh for me and so that
those things have all contributed to my
journey and just sharing my dream with
people and having people come around me
and say hey you you can accomplish these
things no reason why not and that's very
simple message that I like to pass on to
our Canadian youth today you know know
what you want set goals around it share
with other people and you'll be amazed
at what people will enable you to do you
don't do anything big alone you do it as
a team yeah and of course agriculture
agrofood will feature prominently there
at the Stampede this weekend and you've
spoken about the importance between the
link of Agriculture and space what
interests you most about that so food
security is a is a challenge here on the
planet as we go through climate change
and we have to adapt and growing
population but we have the same
challenge of basic needs as we leave
planet Earth and go to the moon and
eventually onto Mars we need to have
that food security we need to be able to
grow it can't bring it all with us and
so solving these issues on the planet
and then taking the solutions to space
with that International partnership is a
really important strategic objective for
Canada and the Canadian space agency and
so the the idea here is that you don't
have to be in the space industry to
contribute to this we're actually
looking for the genius that is already
that already exists across the country
in these areas to help us figure out how
to solve these problems if we can't grow
food in the Canadian Arctic how do you
expect to grow food on Mars and so we
just want people thinking in this way
let's start solve or creating big
solutions for big problems yeah
fascinating stuff and you officially
started your training for the Artemis 2
mission just a couple weeks ago right so
how's it going so far what are the
biggest challenge challenges
well having lots of fun uh with my crew
as we dig in with the experts so the way
it works is you know the actual people
will be in Mission Control when we're
flying around the moon are teaching us
right now their systems they're the
experts on specific parts of the
spacecraft and so we're going through it
I'm learning all sorts of things this
amazing spacecraft but I'm also learning
a lot about the realities of the risk
when you leave the safety even of low
earth orbit you know it's just risky to
go into space but to leave Earth orbit
and head for the moon you become very
very dependent on these systems and so
we have you know we have backup plans
and backup systems and I'm learning all
about that but I'm also getting a real
concrete understanding about just how
big a challenge it is and this is what
we love we love to solve these big Pro
these big challenges I have to tell you
the people I work with at the canyon
space agency at Nasa they love what they
do like this is their passion area and
it's just really fun to see them
creating Solutions in your speaking of
the training in your social media posts
last month I saw you mentioned that you
took part in a four day fast and Vision
Quest Within indigenous organization in
sagging First Nation Manitoba was that
in any way part of your your training
for this Mission what was that like for
you
I've had a lot of authentic uh
connections with indigenous peoples
across Canada and I was invited by an
anishinabi elder to to undergo this
Vision Quest as part of my preparation
for this journey to the moon and it was
very very meaningful for me a lot of
ancient wisdom just really Sage
perspective was shared with me during
you know before and after the fast and
then I spent four days in the woods
without food and water and just a really
tremendous time for me to connect with
Mother Earth before I leave Mother Earth
and head and head to the Moon Yeah well
said uh and what's more nerve-wracking
do you think going to the moon or
hopping on a horse and leading the
Calgary Stampede parade
well having you know basically almost
zero horse riding skills I was
definitely a little bit nervous about
what I was getting into but yesterday I
had a checkout a check ride on the horse
my horse is Cisco it's not Cisco's first
rodeo he's been down this Parade route
before he knows what he's doing and I
feel like I'm in great hands so I'm no
longer feeling nervous about it at all
I'm just really excited to get out there
and connect with people who I mean the
spirit here is awesome I mean the energy
is so great and I'm just excited to
connect with people today on the Parade
route and uh and just reflect back on
them how great our country is and
sometimes we keep ourselves small and I
just want them to in in that moment of
joy and celebration they have remember
that they have a huge impact to bring to
the global Community well we'll be
rooting for you and your mission today
and your mission to the Moon Jeremy
Hansen thanks so much really appreciate
it my pleasure
and if Hansen or others get hungry the
stampede's menu has plenty of items that
are out of this world
like this Cherry Kool-Aid chicken burger
or the ketchup and mustard ice cream
back for another year by popular demand
if you want a hot dog how about this
deep fried dog with pickles and peanut
butter or for a hundred bucks you can
Feast on this foot long made with wagyu
beef and elk and marinated in Cabernet
Sauvignon making me hungry thanks for
watching and gabiola will be with you
here tomorrow and I'll see you again on
Sunday have a great night
foreign
[Music]